if you do not think you deserve success
if you do not think you deserve a bigger
home to be a million dollar producer to
have an outstanding mate our beautiful
well disciplined
children who are productive if you don't
think you deserve them then you'll do
things that will keep you from getting
them there's this Governor on our lives
and it is a governor and it's a it's
your identity it's this internal it's
what you think you're worth a good
person will not take more from the table
of life than they think they're worth or
they think they deserve whatever you've
done up to this point all that it really
is is a duplication it's a reproduction
of what you believe subconsciously that
you deserve and what's possible for your
life it's like a thermostat our lives
get going we start doing really well if
we're 75 degree or and our life gets to
85 and 90 degrees unconsciously we go we
don't know we're doing it oh we start to
cool life back down to get it back to
where we're comfortable
[Music]
the way we alter our life is that we
alter that governor that thermostat and
we start to believe were worth eighty
five degrees of life 95 degrees of life
110 degrees of life
I didn't totally believe it yet I went
out in the world and I carried myself
and I held my head high and I stood
there and I look people in their eyes
and I talked to people as if I was
deserving of everything that this planet
has to offer these low-income houses and
everything is messed up there so living
that's like living dharmic if this if
this is luck this is what I have to live
for then I'm gonna take the chance to
get bought it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter what happens to me
you should save one time he who says he
can
he who says he can't are both usually
right i'ma get it on my bad try if I
don't try what am i doing what kind of
light for my saver
stand up and take like my it's great
do something stopping scared stop
letting the Rays stand up do something
about it so as soon as the I just have
the absence of fear I've I feel it quite
strongly but there are times when if
something is important enough you
believe it enough that you do it in
spite of fear you know what to do you
know what not to eat
[Music]
you know exercise is good for you you
know communication works you know
reading books works you know all this
stuff while you choose not to do it as
the other part I control the kind of a
life I can build and live we all get to
choose our life stories and it's the
choices that define us not our gifts
everybody in this room has many gifts I
have many gifts you can never be proud
of your gifts you can only be proudly of
your choices because those are the
things that you are that you're that you
are accurate and one of the most
important choices that each of us has
and you can choose a life of ease and
comfort or you can choose a life of
service and adventure and when you're 80
which one of those things you think
you're going to be more proud of
becoming a spacefaring civilization is
one of those things that makes you
excited about the future makes you
excited to get up in the morning like
this is something that look forward to
it makes you glad to be if you would be
I see things and I want to make them
real no matter how how hard it takes no
matter what obstacles no matter how many
embarrassing meetings I have to imagine
is happening when I leave does it matter
I'm a doer and a freaking make it happen
er the limitations exist only in our
minds and if you start using
imaginations then you're you know
possibilities they come in at this the
great beauty and gift of my life is that
I was never defined by the box that
other people tried to put me in if
possible is just the word thrown around
by small men who find it easier to live
in the world they've been given than to
explore the power they have to change it
impossible it's not a fact it's an
opinion impossible is potential
impossible is nothing
nothing absolutely nothing is impossible
you can begin again you can believe God
again you can trust again
you can be successful you can overcome
your addictions you can you can feel
alive again
[Music]
[Applause]
trying to train other people
[Applause]
[Applause]
they'll believe
whether state
I may make one or two bad decisions with
my money or my investment that end up
being broke again but I'll never be poor
poor is a state of mind of feeling out
of control
scarcity minded taking pride in being
blue-collar no one should ever take
pride in being people our period I have
to live in abundance you have to
understand that they don't care about
the color of your skin about the level
of your education they want a solution
that put it out there but the scarcity
minded person says oh someone else
opened up a gym you know across the
street for me they're gonna put me out
of business I better charge less
abundant minded person says someone else
opened up the gym across the street for
me I better out service them out work
them out social media them some people
either believe they're smart is there
ever gonna be and that's that so they're
gonna be ego protective and they're
gonna you know try to thwart anything
that makes them feel like they're not
the smartest person or whatever and then
there's people with a growth mindset and
they realized I'm not the smartest
person and I'm certainly not as smart as
I could be so even if I am the smartest
person ever lived I could get a little
bit smarter
I like the advance every year to advance
myself then it was very mentally
everything like to advance myself I've
more fear going back and losing money
summize who i am why i'm about what i'm
gonna take home what i'm gonna create
that raises your game under play against
some of your better than it's gonna go
down play get some abilities
just the skinny record the gamers to go
I want to change your life latest in
wanna raise your standards notes get
around where it's better to play the
game much higher than you are
Daniel's for us
put yourself in circumstances that are
demanding of you past what you think
your capacity is that what you
the water like you do you can throw
yourself out there past where you're
comfortable and knock it out of the
party your brain starts to believe it
repetitiously when you start doing that
you build a new line no matter what I
accomplish you're gonna see me saying I
think I got another idea I can make this
work
I set pretty high goals for myself
they're usually higher than what I think
most other people said from upset for me
people without goals get used by other
people who have them people that don't
have goals work for people who do you
want to be someone who picks up and gets
clear about what you want
make a list hundred one goals I want to
go to Paris I want to you know skydive I
want to bungee cord jump I want to play
the guitar I want to learn to juggle I
want to learn two magic tricks for the
kids I want to go to the Olympics
whatever it is make the list there's a
place deep within us that wants to feel
fulfilled it wants to know that my life
has made a difference but I've left this
place this planet that I've lived on
better than when I arrived
that's someone's life has been probably
touched because of my existence somebody
if you want a motivational video on how
to jumpstart your self-confidence check
out the video link right next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
overcoming the negative conversation
that inner dialogue is going on all the
time even when you don't want it to be
there you can't stop yourself right now